oh how about how about yesterday we went
to go get some uh
lunch and you know how malik was rocking
that [ __ ]
post postal service uniform with his
legs out
dog we ran into a real postal service
and she rolled up and you're like what
the [ __ ] thank you what you doing here
killed one seven seven what are you
doing
you know damn well yeah [ __ ]
i thought we could make this in 94.
that's why i snapped a photo i said get
a picture they have the exact same leg
she was like oh what she rolled up like
what are you doing over here she wrote
up pretty hard she said what you doing
over here
the [ __ ] you trying to take from my
distress she said they put you in santa
monica
she was like don't be serving paper over
here in my stack yeah she said oh that's
the real deal and you have to tell her
i was like yeah yeah he had to tell us
he was false claiming
lacking false claims
she definitely doesn't because you'd
realize that he told her we had a
conversation real quick yeah he was like
i'm a comedian yeah
i was like yo her shoes go hard as [ __ ]
too how much were those oh scrolling on
those those those uh
usps issued boots those are dope
okay those are good ones too fly hell
yeah and the og
uh can she keep her legs shaved man
shout out to that queen shout out to
that queen yeah you even called her
queen
hold on yeah he has the same legs that's
cool
here's the thing about that your legs
your legs actually don't look that bad
in person when you sit down it's more of
your it's more of your the
the meat yeah there's no meat
you're like you're like a nightmare
before christmas pumpkin jack it's just
one did you get that it's like a
mosquito leg it's
just one what the hell pumpkin jack look
like oh bring him up
pumpkin jack you don't have to bring it
up that's the best halloween movie of
all time wait that's true
well nightmare before christmas i saw in
the theaters as a kid
sat on the floor so pacquiao
damn you you spelt skeleton wrong
whatever no i can't there's you know
that's not my goddamn
you have black jeans on right now
[Laughter]
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son